першій бригаді спеціального призначення
імені Івана Богуна 518 батальйону дике
поле фонд Петра Порошенка передає один
автомобіль
передає 500
Перепрошую 50 буржуйок які знаходяться
за моєю спиною
комплект і форми зимового для наших
бійців спальні мішки каремати і
мені здається що ніби ніби все але треба
сказати що оскільки
наші батальйони в тому числі 518 і інші
знаходяться на передовій
безпосередньо близькості до російського
кордону умови там м'яко кажучи
спартанські
і хлопці постійно потребують
утеплення оскільки їм доводиться воювати
в умовах м'яко кажучи польових тому ми
дуже вдячні фонду Петро Порошенко і
п'ятому президенту України Петро
Олексійовича Порошенку за надано
допомогу нашим бійцям
які відстоюють територіальні цінності з
незалежність України і знаходяться в
постійному вогневому контакті з
противниками ці 50 буржуйок поставимо в
бліндажах В окопах вони будуть стояти
е-е наших бійців які знаходяться прямо в
зимових умовах там де немає ні світла ні
води але принаймні їх тепер вже буде
постійно тепло Ну і дуже дякуємо
безперечно за створення е-е кращих умов
для наших бійців в спальні мішки зимова
форма яка їм так само допоможе воювати і
виконувати щось у своїй обов'язок А
скажіть будь ласка про автомобілі навіщо
він так я ну я цю багато типу щоб
перевозити бика щоб поранили переважно
для чогось от саме вам це штурмові
підрозділи штурмові підрозділи
спеціального призначення і вони діють
восковично дуже швидко для них головне в
умовах боя і цієї війни це мобільність
тому автомобілі це витратний матеріал
під час останнього виступом який починав
якраз таки бригада Богуна 518-й
батальйон дике Поло горах е-е знищив
понад 20 20 автомобілів це сталося
буквально там протягом 3-4 днів і цей
шестиденний наступ коштував нам знищення
практично 80% всього автомобільного
парку Тому цей автомобіль буде
використовуватись батальйоном дике поле
для виконання їх завдань Я не знаю кому
він веде або
мінометникам або він піде розвідникам
Але я точно знаю що він буде
використовуватися на самому передку